Chúng là mạnh dùi, mạnh trên hay là mạnh trên gì nữa.
Chúng là dùng dùi gồm dùi ché này.
Cô đánh cái trên này, chứ?
Đúng như là Steve Ramloing lòng nhé.
Cô đánh chúng đồng chăm,
và vang xa, người xưa,
thường dùng trong lẽ hội nông nghiệp,
tổng vừa và tập khổ quân đội chế chật.
Và đây là...
Dạ chứ hình ra vừa mấy.
Để lại, sách vào qua khó vết để chống đông sôi,
mà em chứ phải thật vào.
Để đây là chúng đồng của loa,
thì thích ngay tại thành của loa đông hoàn,
thằng đụng.
Hãy nhìn thấy 1 năm cho năm trước.
Chúng không hoàn.
Nhà, tất cả khi mà loa má cảm xây đi chế,
thì tổ tiên mình đã đúc,
biết này rồi.
Dùi ngoài mình xem film là thử thần tự,
mấy ông loa má làm gì.
Tổ tiên mình ở còn có nhiều cái,
hồi hoàn chán nữa, giấu rồi.
Tại sao?
Mình không biết rồi.
Bây giờ,
và phát trình chống như gì?
Mà chống có hình mặt trời ở trong tâm.
Tỉnh ở,
khởi mặt trời.
Suông quanhi là hình chiến lạc.
Bà người đã nhìn quốc.
Còn người quên.
Chị gạ phy.
Lể các bạn ấy,
Nếu đây là Story High High,
không bao giờ,
hết hạc,
y lại lẽ hợp của tụ tiên.
Hãy nhìn năm trong năm trước.
Ờ.
Có trong họ đến thử không hay là chỉ nhìn thôi.
Thật sę,
để lại tôi,
thích,
tôi cũng có thể thấy thử không làm cho biết.
Nhìn người nào,
nhưng mà,
cái chống này cũng bảo gì không?
Lâu vậy,
màu gạm cũng so chảy dễm bạn,
có thể thấy đến chống là bạn,
phục tông màu gạm này là có gạm lắm rồi.
Chọn mối người là có ông cái.
không biết cũng bảo rồi.
Múc xong này thì cực ki in giết,
vì bạn sẽ không chỉ xem,
mà bạn còn được sự cảm nhận,
được không thay in y bị ở mà tổ tiên,
là dùng trong lẽ hội hạm nhắm trước.
Bánh nó tị trúng đâu,
cảm giác gên nối với hai là trong năm lịch xử nè lập tâm.
Bệ khi,
tháng,
nói ai cái này,
nếu như bạn muốn hủ,
là chúng ta cũng trong bú xong này,
ok.
Ờ.
Hỏi quốc xong tại bảo tăng tiếp theo nha.
Ờ,
cái này sẽ không có bảo khác ở bảo càng.
Hả lộn nhé.